alors bri voilà encore charest a pu
buts el cano encore le retour de brut
sont toujours brut toujours là toujours
dans les bons coups quoi aller 1 1
cette fois ci on a loué le fort
casque d'or les dix doigts d'or de
platine tout est là dedans c'est de
donner le plus sain tout ce que je peux
je donne sont dans la vie faut donner
pour recevoir jean meyer compare souvent
donné comme j'ai dis moi ça me fait
plaisir de faire plaisir qu'on est
habitués dans leur voie
à profiter la ville s'agit quoi
[Musique]
il a voulu faire une mauvaise relance
alors à la compo comme c'est moi
bic à l'ovni contre son malaise le s à
moi à l'école et rescue les morts
suis-je cuit on est mort très intégré
stratégie là on est mort on est moins
bien que le coach des équipes ont bouffé
comment ça va aller au bout je veux nous
faire 113 deux arrivées sont debout je
me suis dit ces professionnels à bazzo
là je joue frérot un peu irrité
numérique en huit tournois jeux brut
fred la paire pas sérieuse là on accourt
bière à l'estac magnifique avec un petit
marseille les portes du très organisés
qui débute qu'au département central
oublié aujourd'hui ça va
c'est skyrock et c'est le cas des
frappes avec jules entre 20h et 21h au
vélodrome l'année prochaine de 22 ans
avoir pelleté et ça va péter aussi avec
un morceau qu'on écoute maintenant voici
alors la zone 7 jours le sexe et alors
là
mauvaise blague il ya des rimes en kilos
pttep te cramer sur le béton armé et
télécharger donne au mot juste devant la
maison n'aura pas d'effet droit marquez
piqué lui que plus je suis sous flash
tropicaux puis de retour d'un regain bnf
à l'euro gros fusils d'assaut des comme
osaka cossardeaux l'occasion aussi pour
la pollution évitée par alger les radars
tronçons le projet très organisé moi
j'en entendu parler c'est un jour vous
n'imaginez pas ce qu explique andrew
appelé la convoquer tout marseille le
sang une ambiance ring ou s'ils avaient
tous les rapports à son tour d'un canapé
voilà je vais faire un projet je vais
réunir tout le monde les anciens et les
nouveaux
mettre en avant des petits talons est
toutefois à double disque de platine
mondiaux de match est là et bien sûr que
je suis une analogie vole sa récente
deuxième en deux matches et voilà ça
créé l'euphorie et c'est parti au delà
de marseille avec bande organisée le son
peut que tout le monde connaît n'y avait
pas forcément de guerre ici à marseille
par comprimé genre c'est pareil avait
pas cette solidarité avant très organisé
ça crée une ambiance dans toute la ville
et dans tous les milieux
c'est énorme dans tous les milieux
on a ressenti le tir le fait que tous
les rapports se rassemblent abbès a
rassemblé tout le monde a repris des
grimpeurs et donc leur staff aussi
lisons sur bonnaire c'est direct sur
leurs mérites
j'ai géré un peu plus de visibilité que
certains tous familles nombreuses ou
marseille c'est le plaisir vérité mais
nous on est tous super eagles contre
10,6 mind tombola tétouan
[Musique]
c'est ici en france on est beaucoup
critiqué les gens souvent c'est très
simple de critiquer les gens c'est très
simple tout etc
mais on se rend pas compte que que jul
non seulement ouvert les portes pour
tellement de personnes vraiment parce
qu'à chaque fois madame fait des planète
rap ensemble moi j'ai vu le mettra en
avant parce que oui veut pas se mettre
en avant
c'est pas un mec a un ego démesuré qui
pourrait dire régionalement en avant et
s'est fait sans prétention c'est pas
fait pour se dire ouais tu sais je mais
déjà en avance et fait vraiment avec une
passion avec le 10ème légion
là dans ma tête me battre il a parlé des
fortes houles du temps à trouver la
bonne visibilité qu est-ce qui va faire
pour aux clients faire pour arriver à
toucher tout le monde tu vois où a
touché une un public âgé de donner le
plus
tout ce que je peux vous donner tout ce
que je peux je donne ma vérité des cédez
jamais les oublier en fait façon dans la
vie faut donner pour recevoir j'ai envie
qu'il faut pas vous recevoir pour donner
[Musique]
le gis jan routine qui va finir dans la
piscine avec moi ben brik a bien sûr
parce que tu peux finir en casse bélier
dans la piscine c'est comme ça parce que
là et je crois dire un guet-apens qui se
prévoit je vais me rafraîchir rythme et
voilà on est prêt les vacances peuvent
commencer c'est parti mon abonnement en
toupie des couleurs moi je travaille dur
en ait eu manque que des couleurs moi je
moi je
[Rires]
et avec mes téléphones
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
oh à bruay et merci prix
quand on sait que tout le monde enfin
confinement fin du couvre-feu
merci bien s'appuient
par nature du rapport s'est régalé
j'espère que l'album il vous plait j'ai
vu que des bons retours 300 donc merci
merci à tous encore et voilà ça
continuera toujours est et fait
attention par la suite puisque à des
raz-de-marée qui arrivera avec votre
arrivée
moi au bout
[Musique]
john